as you can see this eye is not blinking
i can't smile on this side of my face
this nostril will not move
so there's full paralysis in this side
of my face
justin bieber gives a serious health
update revealing to his fans that he has
temporary face paralysis causing him to
cancel upcoming shows obviously
as you can probably see from my face
um i have uh
this syndrome called uh
um
ramsey hunt syndrome
and it is from
this
virus
that um
[Music]
attacks the nerve in my ear
and my
facial nerves
and has caused my face to have paralysis
the pop star has been on the road for
his justice tour hours before what was
supposed to be a stop in toronto justin
gets candid about why he has to postpone
future shows until further notice for
those who are frustrated by my
cancellations of the next shows
i'm just physically obviously not
capable of doing them
uh this is pretty serious as you can see
um
i wish this wasn't the case
but obviously my body's telling me i
gotta slow down
um
i hope you guys understand
and uh
i'll be using this time to just rest and
relax and
get back to 100 so that i can um
do what uh
i was born to do purpose is such an
important
thing in life and
i just wanted to use my platform to tell
people that in the meantime the 28 year
old singer says he's doing facial
exercises as part of his recovery so he
can get back on stage
this is just the latest in an emotional
tour for the biebs
the singer broke down in tears during
the mexico leg of his justice tour days
after the texas school shooting at robb
elementary i've been
having a lot of cries lately
back in april justin and his team went
on stage in buffalo new york what's up
buffalo
this stop came hours after a racially
motivated mass shooting at a local
grocery store
you guys probably heard what happened
pretty horrible stuff
but um
i'm looking forward to tonight looking
forward to getting on that stage and
doing what we do best and having a good
time and bringing joy to the city the
pop star started his show with the
moment of silence for the fallen victims
you know as we know
[Music]
there's been tragedy in the city
but what we're gonna do tonight
is we're gonna honor those people
and i would love
if we could just take
a moment of silence
that same month justin's wife haley
experienced a health scare of her own
definitely
the scariest moment of my life the model
underwent heart surgery not long after
doctors found a blood clot in her brain
they did some scans and they were able
to see that i had suffered a small blood
clot to my brain basically it's like
having a mini stroke at the time haley
shared how justin stood by her side
throughout the whole ordeal
basically i was
sitting at breakfast with my husband and
all of a sudden i felt this really weird
sensation that kind of like traveled
down my arm from my shoulder all the way
down to my fingertips justin was like
are you okay and i just
didn't respond because i wasn't sure
right away he asked for somebody to
please call 9-1-1 and get a doctor
despite his latest diagnosis justin
shared a message of hope for his
believers
it's gonna be
it's gonna be okay and i have hope and
um i trust god and um i trust that this
is all gonna
it's all for a reason and um
i'm not sure what that is right now but
in the meantime
i'm gonna rest and
i
i love you guys
you